hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to drunk minecraft with Wade
and Bobbsey hug hi everybody hi buddy hi
Bobbi as I put the huge bottle of gin to
my mouth so we are still in techid as
you could see and we are having our own
little misadventures here we today today
which is five minutes after our last
episode for us but for you guys it's
like a few days in later we are going to
be trying to bit what did we decide
we're gonna do open the portal what are
we just playing whoa whoa whoa whoa stop
with the portal spam my server is going
crazy what we should have never got
these swords out this is bad what sort
is that hang on what is that
the writ is a rift blade opens a
temporary door special teleport attack
and rotates existing doors oh so that's
why it's doing this crazy Oh Oh what
does that have to do with everything
stupid for this fairly how do i how do I
use scoot forward I want to go through
one of these doors
I want to port forward oh my god guys
well I saw it there's a port ah port owl
has a port oh I see it stop closing it
I'm trying to open it here come out the
portal should be ooh hi Bob hi welcome
back
did anybody know that you could have
wished right kind of graphics
oh yeah we're supposed to be doing
something shut up I'm going in do
anything wait were you in a different
I was yeah what's happening my servers
going dimension 13 14 15 this this is a
string theory exercise yes I'm going
this one
whoa I went in too far I poured into the
portal hang on go in come here come here
wait
come ere away go in this door this one
over here on this side
come on going this door woof oh my god
hi guys go to random portals in this
dimension have a tier one dungeon key no
I don't know but it opens this box I
just placed what you know what I think
about the box really Oh Bob why that's
what I think about this recording don't
call me try get your precious box is now
weighed we can fly you know that right
shut up okay so yeah we were gonna build
something what were we gonna build we're
gonna build the Powerpuff Girls that's
right yeah that was right we're gonna
build that we decided to build eight
bubbles to destroy more people's
childhood we're gonna build the
Powerpuff Girls but we have a rule no
penises cuz that would be really weird
which one is mine I don't know the green
one Oh him I remember him alright the
[ __ ] Mountain is killing those cows at
the bottom just so you know
eat [ __ ] cows hey kids show kids show
for ya poop cows poop cows Wow
wait that's actually
cows you're doing a great job there wait
no oh that's way better
Oh blossoms gonna be made out of
emeralds okay hang on wait hang on wait
what was mine I want to build the
Powerpuff Girls now when there's so much
Tekkit stuff to explore what about
varied levels what is that it's not Bo
[Laughter]
where are you Oh oh my god that way how
do I place it looks like Brunhilde the
bubbles yeah was this was that sister
that they made cuz they wanted another
Power Puff girl was her name the really
really weird one uh bunny thou visit
forever bunny
no remember bunny look what I found
look look wait look where are you look
I'm right behind bubbles just stole my
courage was TNT on them oh hey come on
come on mark was just trying to have
some good clean family fun oh she's got
eyes in the back of her head yes she
does
now she has TNT hair how do I make them
go off ask how to detonate TNT yeah but
how TNT on a minecart
gonna light it from the bottom
underneath the card and I'm gonna see
what a torch placer what is a torch
place
try torch what are these things but
they're not understand magic there's
seriously there's there's so much stuff
here okay TNT no go boom
let me see if I can if I put TNT here
and set it off oh whoa wait no no I know
I'll pick out more than that
can we play TNT tag who love to play TZ
tank that sounds horrible
that sounds incredible I'm building a
powerpuff girl flying oh oh well done
there Bobbo right oh that's not the same
at all you know what screw I'm going
back to building a nuke you guys you
guys yeah you nevermind I'm gonna we
struggled I'm gonna build oh no does she
know she doesn't know Oh aren't they
bringing back the Powerpuff Girls didn't
I see that somewhere god I hope so yeah
I love that show
The Beatles episode of that show is like
the greatest thing I've ever seen in my
life it was a Beatles episode of the
Powerpuff Girls episode where the whole
episode was Beatles references really
and the best the best line ever written
for a TV show
well one of the best there's a scene
where the professor comes out and mojo
jojo's girlfriend mojo oh no or
something like that she starts dating
him and then he doesn't do what
terrorist things anymore yeah and then
she's like playing the piano and the
professor just comes out and says it's
okay girls Sunday monkey won't play
piano song play piano song I lost it I
don't deserve it
there's that Beatles song where there's
a French line that's like so named well
it's in French it's not in English what
it sounds like
some day monkey won't play piano song
ah you know I probably saw that episode
but I was too stupid at the time so it
went way over my head and is this an
eyeball yes what is it I don't remember
that why screw it I'm working on more
techid stuff because there's too much
good stuff in here I'm doing what we
said we were gonna do yeah Europe made
[ __ ] Mountain you can't say anything
yeah on top of my magical treasure chest
Oh
Oh golly oh man I can't spawn chicken
what wait what was designed for this
[Laughter]
sounds even worse
oh you made it sound like that yeah you
made that sound like that thing that it
sounded like that's too young for what
we're trying to do out here stop being
weird ways which should abandon we
should definitely abandon this attempt
at the Powerpuff Girls because it's
gonna devolve into something horrible
and then I'm gonna get banned from
YouTube and no one's gonna ever ever
ever ever ever today I want to see what
I'm doing here oh yeah sorry
that way no I don't see
this is a NASA workbench my god it can
make a rocket build it we need to go to
space how do we do this are there rocket
parts look it's in the yet tier 1 rocket
program yeah okay
rocket um gotta and launchpad got a
rocket engine rocket fins NASA workbench
schematic tier 2 rocket coming soon so
that's not in there yet
ok oh my god oh my god oh we're gonna
how do we make rocket parts oh no I'm
gonna make a launch pad oh my god we
found what we're gonna do Oh screw
bubbles and everything like that screw
all the viral girls this oh my god I
don't know if we have the mental
capacity to do this oh it's gonna be you
won't oh you can only make a 3x3 wall it
turned into something Bob look over here
Bob over here buddy mommy I'm trying
what's this you see this just kaboom
Wow I made launch pads come look I'm
trying to figure out how the hell to
make a rocket engine look up online look
online I mean it says on here but
there's like a bunch of part yeah I
found I got like a rocket engines in VAR
info these are just made-up thing here I
got there's rocket engine I put him on
damn it
I got rocket engine um and uh if we had
the patience and or the skill we could
build this would do this you can spawn
things with the numbers right but I
don't know what to spawn spawn five five
eight one spawn a bunch of those and
five five eight two and wait hold on
five five eight one ten five five five
eight one yeah it doesn't exist
that's rocket engine it doesn't i have
rocket engine up here I have also need
rocket fins I had those um I'm gonna
search for like fuselage how do you
spell fuselage F you so Lodge I am
finishing my bubbles damn about why we
got more important things to do I've
gotten so close no one cares what a [ __ ]
spawn spaceship Oh
5 5 8 7 : ooh I got it I'll get the pre
fueled one yeah it's a 3d model can I
swing this I can't swing this where are
you all right next to you you douche no
you're not look behind you
I don't see you anywhere I see two
platforms on the ground because I'm
holding the weight hand do you see me
now oh no you see me now Oh disappear
why are you invisible man hey I got
[Laughter]
you're inside it no you're not oh yeah
you are
I'm sorry how do you make a cool
how do you make it go launch launching
push space twice that it launches it's
not cuz I'm in I'm in oh my why I think
we're in creative mode so this isn't
gonna work
I'm staying away why is my hand up
[Laughter]
oh my god
why bah height meter I'm in space
orbiting no that's so cool
I've got 89 percent fuel ah hey I got it
how do I make my vision oh man han wait
han I'm gonna build you a new launch pad
Bob hello are you back on ground now no
I'm still flying okay I need to get up
there cuz the my fans need to see this
so hey I'm gonna try to do this
correctly okay I'm in it now I'm like
launching oh my god launch launch I'm
not launching I'm oh my god I'm creating
a space station
nine eight seven six five four three one
oh my god it's working I'm bad guys
lately enjoy your stupid bubbles
Robonaut I'm in a lunar lander what are
you going to the moon oh my god I'm in a
lunar lander how is this even possible
my mind is exploding this is so crazy
Wade you are missing out you don't even
know oh my god boys you don't even know
this probably would have been more worth
it if we actually spent the time to get
the materials to build this but at the
same time we would have never done it
oh my god you guys are actually in space
then yeah it's landing on the moon wait
Bob when does it end my height meter
says I'm like halfway through space you
reach the top you get a menu to create a
space station or go to the moon I'm
going to the mood I'm gonna meet I'll
meet you on the moon Bob I'll meet you
on the route Wade whenever you want to
join us
I'm on the moon
I got gravity's lower I'm going to the
moon said [ __ ] true I guess
oh wow much of a surprise so hold space
to slow down oh my god how do I get to
you guys the spaceship
it kind of just lands itself whoa if you
just fell way to build a spaceship yeah
you're such a dick do I need an ion
thruster yes you need three of those
mark are you coming to the moon yes I am
a very landing wait where am I
I don't see anything it's all black when
does this happen
I see I see like a landing trail for you
or something I don't see anything it
looks like I'm just hang in there it
lands itself just hang in there I'm
coming to your landing zone I think I'm
moving
no you're moving the draw this other
spaceship how do I put it near the
launch pad see I see where you're gonna
land lunch at my movie I don't think I'm
moving you could right click to get out
maybe you're landed already no I don't
think so I think I would fall to my
death but I'm in game mode does it have
a speed on your screens - no no speed
like no speed I got out of the lander I
can jump down probably fine whoa ok I'm
falling into blackness I'm scared Bob
I'm scared I'm on the moon I don't give
[ __ ] I think I think I'm watching 3 is
that a bad sign your fire is green oh my
god yeah oh my god we create footprints
so three minutes ago yeah exactly wait
[Music]
little bar on the side like your head as
the rocket ship permanent footprints
this is amazed
I have with me on the moon a minecart
filled with TNT this is so cool
Wade you are missing out man you are not
on your way faster if we if I build
another rocket ship here will I will we
be able to get back I want to try build
a space station I'm gonna look up what
you need to build a space station whoo
okay I'm gonna work when we were going
to the moon there was an option to build
a space station in orbit around the
earth
yeah I don't even know what that would
do no wonder all the ticket stuff had
like rocket ships and whatnot this is
amazing so wait I'm almost to the top
what happens overworld or moon what do I
select a moon like a moon a moon oh
we're all the moon you stupid monster
bitchin yes yes and it's a different
dimension whoa okay look it's it's it's
earth up above did you see that Bob yeah
Wow he's gone I think he smashed into
the ground
no that's the graphic where it shows you
where he's landing oh okay
like plummeting to his doom how do I get
out of this thing right click you can
fall you can fall oh that's like in a
really far away third-person perspective
no yes no yes maybe I don't know I don't
know where are you I don't know I got a
power glove power gauntlet um you just
right click to get out of the ship and
then jump off the edge
you'll fall faster jump off the edge of
what your ship I'm floating on my butt
right now I don't say you guys want to
see some funny stuff yes look over
towards me are you taking off where you
going Bob Bob where are you going
oh I get it Oh oh that's kind of awesome
right yeah
cool this is like the coolest thing I've
ever seen them like I had no idea I'm
here wait where are you it's about damn
time and you know what I'm gonna do now
that we're on the moon we're gonna nuke
the hell out of this man where are my
lyrics can we mine on the moon can we
like do that this load is brake blocks
oh no I think they took out nukes no I'm
going to the center of the moon there's
no nukes there are there are no nukes
what is that
there's no nukes no nukes why are there
any nukes or or nuke it what is this I
don't know there's stuff down here wait
where are you guys down in a hole
straight down to the center of the moon
oh and no wait what I know they're like
moon rocks are there mom I got oh no oh
oh no oh no what what whoa whoa all
right we're okay like that I'm gonna
blow some holes in the moon just to see
what we're dealing with was facade oh
okay I hope everyone watching in choices
even like half as much as we're enjoy
everyone this is this freaking pool area
this is the coolest thing I've seen in a
long time in Minecraft this is amazing
I'm just gonna blow some holes in the
moon see what we Bambang ewwww
okay what is this material anyway do you
guys want to be out of creative mode up
here no we might die from oxygen
deprivation no we got octavo I heard
some explosions oh I've got an idea I'm
gonna make a really cool shaped hole oh
yes what she said boom good bang I don't
see a bottom to this oh there is some
kind of or here what is this there's
gray stuff and yellow stuff yeah yeah
cheese curd the moon is made of cheese
alright alright I'll accept I'll allow
it
I'll see how much damage one TNT can do
on the moon yes yes I do
just one right just one you're not
messing with me no it's just one that's
awesome that was just one yeah that was
just one oh hey where are you guys in
the big holes in explosion where do you
think we are look for the giant Tower of
TNT let me do mine sooo I'm coming wait
wait
TP Lord Mannion 7 Mario back hi what do
you have on what you have like a
spacesuit what the hell Bob do you see
this we are wrong I should have been
thinking ahead Bob look at Wade you
gotta forget spacesuit on it's awesome
you look I like the Metroid dude Looney
gotta be lookout
the whole dowhat out of the hole get in
the hole get in my hole ooh what is this
gray stuff
Oh what is the gray stuff dude we
figured it out don't we say what oh yeah
that's right well do you guys want to be
out of creative mode no oh I get it
that's like bedrock for the moon but
since we're in creative mode we can
break right through it okay universe
what yeah I have an idea it's gonna take
a minute for me to set this up we don't
have that long we got like three minutes
left
Bob what are you doing down there
oh oh god oh no oh no this top block is
called moon turf moon turf
all right wait I'm taking you and me out
of game out of creative mode all right
this is happening you have a freaking
space suit on what's going on why don't
ya Oxendine in an oxygen tank heavy
oxygen tank here we go okay heavy oxygen
tank and then wait can I fly around
underneath I don't know you need an
oxygen mask gear and heavy oxygen tank I
think that's what you need let me try
this
I will experiment on myself so that you
do not need to subject yourself to any
danger T tank gear oxygen mask
Bob this is the thing that you had on
before
I had this on yeah this glass thing
around your head that's an oxygen mask I
was an oxygen mask why did I have that I
don't know wait what do you do
where did you find that I found
underneath the BOD the bedrock of the
Moon
Clarke where do you find that you just
type in oxygen in your search bar solid
oxycotin that's not it you need oxygen
mask gear and tank
I need another tank though I'm making
another hole I really like these
enormous holes Oh what's a sensor card
no sensor card was for the other thing
in Tekken we're not doing any of that
we're actually out of time can we make a
moon quarry yes we can so much to do we
should build a house oh I feel like
that's a lot like building a house on
earth but okay we should build moon
trees and then cows on their heads
cuz the [ __ ] would just fly away can we
make like an enclosure and then put dirt
in it and then grow stuff like up of
dirt yeah hey how did you equip that you
put it on your head when you're out of
creative mode well you don't have time
we'll do this okay we're done so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you still want to see more Tekkit we
don't know if you do or not we don't
haven't we record this on a bunch
nice rocket weighed and made a big hole
congratulations Bob so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that we've
done and as always we will see
in the next video bye bye say bye guys
[Applause]
what you can't fool me
[Music]
[Music]
treason